الفرنسي كريم بنزيما يودعوا ريال مدريد
ويوقع لنادي الاتحاد
اجتماع عاصف بين مالديني ومالكي ميلان
كومباني يحضر للموسم الجديد بطريقه خاصه
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
توصل نادي الاتحاد السعودي لاتفاق مع
المهاجم الفرنسي كريم بنزيما لتمثيليه
خلال السنوات الثلاث المقبله خبر تفاعل
معه رواد السوشيال ميديا بقوه وتصدر
عناوين الصفحات الرياضيه وغير الرياضيه
حول العالم وكان بنزيما قد نال جائزه
الكره الذهبيه شهر اكتوبر الماضي ومن
المنتظر ان يشارك مع في بطوله كاس العالم
للانديه والتي ستقام في السعوديه شهر
ديسمبر المقبل
وكان بنزيما قد ودع الفريق الاسباني اليوم
الثلاثاء بعدما اعلن النادي رحيله في وقت
سابق وقال بنزيما في المؤتمر الوداعي بانه
اراد انهاء مسيرته في ريال مدريد لكن
الحياه تفاجئ البعض بفرص جديده البينز خاب
اخر مبارياته مع الريال يوم الاحد الماضي
وانهى مسيرتهم الفريق بهدف من ركل الجزاء
قبل ان استبدلات حتى تصفيق حار من طرف
الجماهير
بعد تجديد عقده مؤخرا يبدو ان ايام
الاسطوره باولو مالديني مع نادي ميلان
اصبحت معدوده وهذا بعد الاجتماع العاصف
الذي جمعه بالملك كاردينالي الذي رفض
الخطه الجديده للتعاقدات الخاصه بالماركات
الحاليه اضافه لتحضيرات النادي للموسم
الكروي المقبل وكشفت تقريرا صحفيه ايطاليه
الانتهاء العلاقه بين الطرفين بعد فشل كل
منهما في فرض سيطرته على الاخر
في خبرنا الاخير والغريب انطلقت منذ اليوم
تحضيرات الصعده الجديد للدوري الانجليزي
الممتاز نادي بيرلي حيث لم يمنح كومباني
مدرب الفريق اي راحه للاعبيه ولو حتى
للاحتفال بهذا الصعود وخذ فريق بيرلي 46
مباراه في دوري الدرجه الاولى تعرض خلالها
للخساره في ثلاث مناسبات فقط كما جمع 100
ونقطه واحده